this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
I'm thanks Pacey sense sorry let me a
little bit of an issue there with the
slides hi my name is Bill bill Burnett
I'm the director of the design program
at Stanford and I want to talk to you
about teams and how you transform them
into high performance so the innovative
teams using the methods that we talked
about Stanford that we call design
thinking so a couple of maybe start with
a few definitions
what's a team well it's really just you
know you all are work on teams I'm sure
in your organization's teams are just
collections of people formed around some
kind of an organizational tasks and
maybe a task force to look at improving
productivity it may be a team related to
a project or a product that you're
developing but I'd like to also think
about teams in a different way you know
I want you to think about teams as a
collection of behaviors and norms teams
are like that as I said just a
collection of people and people have a
certain expectation of how they should
behave when they come to work when
they're on this team and those normative
behaviors are really what we're going to
talk about transforming when we talk
about moving teams from less innovative
to a more innovative stance and so our
our premise is that if you want to
transform your teams you need to change
behaviors and you know we'll take it's
like to take a very simple behavior
change sort of idea let's say it's just
only February and your new year's
resolution was that you want to diet
this year you want to lose some weight
well you can read books about losing
weight it doesn't actually do much it's
just sort of a cognitive thing you can
think about losing weight again that
doesn't necessarily cause the pounds to
go away
what you actually need to do to lose
weight is to change your behavior right
you need to substitute an old behavior
having a doughnut every morning for
breakfast for the new behavior maybe
just having you know a bold low-fat
oatmeal or yogurt so once you you can't
you can't
the premise in psychology is you can't
change behavior
cognitively you change behavior by
substitution so the two things we're
going to ask you to look at in terms of
changing your teams into high
performance innovation teams is the two
behaviors around brainstorming and some
new behaviors around brainstorming and
also about changing space and I'll
explain space and it's the kind of
interesting issue in itself when we get
there so you're going to substitute old
behaviors new behaviors for old and the
best way to change behavior particularly
if you're the manager of these teams is
by modeling you act the way you want
others to act and they will mob will
have to you and by the way this takes a
little bit of patience because it takes
about eight weeks according to the
cognitive psychologists for a behavior
to become a habit in an individual
that's an interesting interesting number
if you start you know if you've studied
you started dieting in January
you still haven't reached eight weeks
yet so whatever you're doing is not it's
still an effort to substitute the new
behavior for the old it's not become a
habit
and since teams are collections of
people you're not going to embed these
new behaviors in your team and anything
less than about two months it's probably
going to take three or four so one of
the things we notice when people come to
the d.school they take an innovation
class or they take a bootcamp and then
they go back to their organizations they
have some change in their behavior but
after a while it seems to peter out and
it's really an issue of getting to that
eight-week threshold so it takes about
eight weeks for new behavior to become a
habit another definition you know what's
this design thinking thing well it
started at Stanford David Kelley is the
founder of IDEO probably one of the
world's premier innovation product
development and innovation organizations
he also founded our new Institute to D
School where we're teaching Design
Thinking to everyone on the Stanford
campus and to leaders in the industry so
his quote is we believe the next
generation of innovation innovators and
leaders need to be great
design thinkers so what is this design
thinking thing well it's really a
different approach to problem solving
it's very dynamic and it works
particularly well in what's called an
unbounded or poorly bounded problems
most of the issues we deal with in
business today are this class of problem
competitors are changing too rapidly to
really you know model or understand
strategies fail often because the
outside conditions are changing so
rapidly that the strategic planning
process is too slow we utilize in order
to solve that we utilize a lot of
iteration and we use a lot of
prototyping to ask questions for rapid
learning and improvement we have a sort
of fail early to succeed quickly
strategy and we use a lot of different
methods for generating alternative ideas
so that we can increase the number of
innovation opportunities we have which
we believe creates the opportunity to
have more innovative outcomes we're
going to talk about one of those
alternative generation techniques
brainstorming in some detail in this
webinar but the real key I think in
design thinking is many people look at
the problem solving modes that we use
ideation brainstorming morphological
analysis prototyping and think that's
the key the true key is actually that
it's a it's a different approach to
problem finding but we what we find and
the people that we work with both in the
academic setting in the business setting
is that often for a lot of good reasons
people are working on the wrong problem
they're working on a problem that's more
of a symptom or an adjacent problem and
if they the highest leverage refined
isn't backing up and reframing what is
the problem you're trying to solve and
we do that by using ethnography and
empathy and observation of the actual
solution space itself of the people in
their environment who have the problem
to redefine what we call a point of view
and we use prototyping and other methods
to sort of reveal those latent needs and
make sure that we're actually working on
the right problem so it's but
as a problem-solving but a problem
finding approach that I think makes this
so powerful and of course it's a news
perspective on value creation because
it's human centered and sort of a
co-created practical creation process
which focused us on real user needs we
have a process diagram I'm always
cautious when I put this up because it
looks like it's sort of a linear thing
we start with empathy and we end with
tests really it's a circular process and
you can enter the process at any point
you can have an technology that you're
looking for a need you can have a need
that you're looking for you know a
problem to solve but we basically you
know we like to break this down so that
it can be taught we start with empathy
which is where the need finding and
ethnography occurs we do a definition or
point of view exercise which is where
the redefining of the problem comes in
ideation which contains all the ways of
having lots and lots of ideas we believe
if you have a lot of ideas to choose
from you will choose better we prototype
and then we test and then we come back
around to the the definition the point
of view and see if something that we've
learned in the process of interrogating
this poorly bounded problem through
prototyping changes our point of view
and it often does and then through that
process we saw zoom in co-creating
solutions and this has turned out to
work in things from product development
to service development to designing new
experiences sometimes people aren't sure
what I mean when I talk about experience
design think of Disneyland's probably
the best designed experience on the
planet from the moment you hit the
parking lot to entering the park to the
day that you have in any of the Disney
properties you're inside a completely
designed experience in every touchpoint
has been considered so that's Design
Thinking to define and process diagram
and also the notion of behavior change
it's the way that we're going to
approach changing teams and team
dynamics to move them towards more of an
innovative basis and one of the things
that we teach a lot and work a lot on
and have developed some
you thinking on is brainstorming and I'm
sure everybody you know that's out in
webinar land here has done brainstorm if
I could have put a pull slide in I
would've asked you but I'll bet you a
hundred percent of you have been to
something called a brainstorming session
or a brainstorm my guess is if I had
been observing what you were doing it
might not have been fully might not
fully meet the criteria that I have for
brainstorming because part what I would
look at in research is you know how do
we actually create more creative
students here and executives and our
seminars and brainstorming is a key a
key tool and just recently I'm not sure
how many people saw this but in The New
Yorker and the January 30th for New York
it just came out last week there was an
article by a writer Jonah Lehrer who has
picked up a bunch of research and this
research has been around since the 50s
and 60s and 70s and his you know the
title was sort of you know to generate
some buzz as journalists will do the
title of his article was that
brainstorming doesn't work and in that
he cites some research that says the
brainstorm is actually inefficient and
one of the notions that most people have
about brainstorming is that you would
come to a session you'd have lots and
lots of ideas and it somehow that the
group of people could generate more and
better ideas than people working alone
but in a number of studies and
particularly the original work on this
was done at Yale it has been shown that
people have twice as many ideas if you
just simply count the number of ideas
they write down on a page working alone
as they do in brainstorming sessions so
that's interesting because I think most
people would think brainstorming
generates more ideas but their research
shows and it's been repeated and we have
no doubt that this is true
but people will have more ideas working
alone than in groups
now if you look at this if you look at
the research specifically the
brainstorming that has been done in
these groups has been done with people
that I would quantify as novices novice
meaning I'll define these categories in
the next slide but novices meaning
people who essentially have less than a
hundred hours of his experience with
anything typically in the studies a
group of people are brought together
they're taught the brainstorming rules
you know defer judgment go for volume
have wild ideas those are the basic
rules we have other rules like one idea
at a time be visual things like that but
they're taught the rules and then
they're set to brainstorm on you know
topic that the researchers have created
so one thing to notice is that they have
this is the first time or maybe the
first few times they've ever done this
in a structured format and then the
figure of Merit the thing the researcher
is trying to measure is captured at the
end of each session so at the end of the
session I take all the pages off the
wall of all the notes or post-its that
have been placed up and I maybe measure
the number of ideas or in some cases
they've measured the diversity of ideas
how many ideas are off the central topic
and trying to measure
you know how wild the ideas are but it's
always captured right at the end of the
session so although I completely agree
and I think it seems obvious I'm not
quite sure how you can get a PhD doing
such obvious research but people get
them I guess that I can write things
down faster than I can talk and
particularly if I have to wait for other
people to speak in a brainstorming
session or brainstorming modality we
will not generate the same number of
ideas as we could if we just sat on you
know sat by myself in a room and wrote
down every idea I could write as fast to
it but I want to look dig a little bit
deeper and I want to
introduce an analogy that I use and that
we we teach here and I want you to think
a little bit about jazz I don't know how
many people out there like jazz or maybe
play jazz or listen to it but jazz is an
interesting art form
when is far probably the one true
American art form it was born in America
and has traveled all over the world but
is absolutely an American invention and
jazz is the one form of music that when
musicians sit down to play a piece to
play a song they expect to play it
differently than they've ever played it
before they expect to improvise now they
have a structure and have a song and
they have a chart which lists the you
know the chord changes and the melody
but there will be parts of the chart
that say you know sixteen bars improvise
eight bars improvise so they aren't told
what to play they're simply told what
the song is and it's truly one of these
interesting mind-body problems right
I've a saxophone player and I know how
to move my fingers to make the keys or
the notes either that come out of the
saxophone so that's something I have to
have practice and been good at but and
I'm following the song along so I have a
cognitive mode going in my mind but at
some point the bandleader will turn to
me and say go and now I have to create
something but literally I've never heard
before it's not written down for me and
I need to invent it completely out of my
mind so how's that work Stanley Crouch
is a jazz critic MacArthur Genius grant
Award winner he programs art jazz for
the Lincoln Center wrote this in a
Forbes article a while back and I love
it because it's a it's just it's I think
it's true then and it's even more true
now as we've you know 10-15 years later
he's a jazz is the one art form that's
resolved the so-called mind-body problem
jazz players playing in the moment and
creating music they've never
heard before literally inside the
structure of the song I think just like
Rain Stormers inside the structure of a
problem trying to create solutions that
they don't know they know right and he
said further in the digital age our
organizations and our careers will
become more and more closely aligned
with the Jazz Ensemble we'll find
ourselves improvising with greater and
greater confidence and fearing less and
less the imaginative powers of the
individual how many of you you know in
your organization's today have seen this
shift in the last 10 or 15 years we
talked about it in educational which is
educating students to know the answer
isn't going to be enough we need to
educate for creativity we need to
educate for sort of multidisciplinary
interests we need to educate people to
look at systems and synthesis rather
than just analysis if we can't put
information in context and make it
valuable and real you know we're not
doing what we need to do to educate this
next generation of technologists and
leaders and crutch was saying this back
in 96 that you know are because we live
in a sort of post Information Age our
jobs and the way we work will become
more and more like a jazz ensemble and I
love this analogy because I think it's
absolutely true a jazz ensemble is just
like a brainstorming group and so if I
was a psychologist and I was trying to
see what is the capability of a
brainstorming group I might go get the
Miles Davis sextet Bill Evans Pittman
greatest jazz piano players in the world
Jimmy Cobb Paul Chambers Cannonball
Adderley and John Coltrane John Coltrane
for goodness sakes on saxophone
that's a sextet they created the album
kind of blue which was is is the
best-selling jazz album of all time it's
it's quadruple platinum certified sales
and you wouldn't expect to sit in as an
amateur who maybe just learned the
saxophone and can play a few notes maybe
read a little music you wouldn't expect
to sit in with the Miles Davis sextet
and create great jazz because you have
to practice
and when you when you practice anything
brainstorming a musical instrument
anything any technical technical skill
at first the mechanics are the
difficulty how do I think in the moment
how do I have ping-pong ideas off of
each other how do I listen to another
and have an idea how do i free associate
and not get stuck these are difficult
mechanics and then even after you get
good at that you could be really good at
playing scales and playing playing
brainstorming games perfect mechanics do
not make perfect improvisation
improvisation is a completely different
skill and it's partly a 10,000 hour
problem now there are some psychologists
who believe that in 10,000 hours anyone
can become an expert there are others
who believe that may be a simplification
but we look at we look at chess masters
we look at golfers we look at other
athletes there seems to be a threshold
around 10,000 hours that creates
expertise which in fact is mastery its
master of the sport so that that things
that have our mechanical have become
habitual they're relegated to either
muscle memory or unconscious competence
and people move into this mastery level
where they can do things that no one
else can do but it takes about a hundred
hours to move from a novice to any sort
of competency yeah there's only a couple
of three weeks but you know hard work
and you know and we're talking about
moving from you know I can't play the
saxophone to I actually can make some I
can play a scale I can make notes I
could probably get to there in three or
four weeks of practice but it takes a
good thousand hours to go from
competency to any sort of expertise and
since I'm at 10,000 hours to go to
mastery so in the same way that you
would not expect to sit in with the
miles day of a sextet and be able to
hold your own with those musicians who
have practiced maybe hundreds of
thousands of hours to get to the
effortless mastery that they have as
jazz players why would you think that
mastering the discipline of sort of
letting go and innovating in the moment
would take any less time than that
this is not easy stuff to do accessing
massively parallel unconscious
processing accessing visual information
in your brain and being able to
synthesize the information of the group
on the fly in the moment takes a lot of
practice so when I see you know when I
see psychologist saying brain storming
doesn't work what I actually hear them
saying is beginning saxophone players
can't play jazz I believe that's true
but I think when you have competent
players players who put in a hundred
hours or so brainstorming can be
effective and you want to measure more
than just what happened at the session
because as you've probably known design
this innovation sessions brainstorming
sessions idea sessions whatever you want
to call them that's a moment in time and
then people leave the meeting and how
many of you have had the experience of
the next morning after that really good
brainstorming session has the office but
nothing seemed to come out of it the
next morning you're standing in the
shower and suddenly you have a good idea
that that piece of strategy that you
were looking for suddenly comes to you
or that product notion or the way you
want to position something or that new
channel idea suddenly comes to you right
that's another thing by the way guy
named Herbert Benson at harvest has
studied he's a physician he wrote a book
called the relaxation response you can
take a look at that I'm not going to
speak to that specifically but there is
a biological model for why you have
ideas 1224 hours after a brainstorming
session or a session where you load your
unconscious thinking with with the
problem so you want to look at things
that are beyond the session itself
because often after the session 12 to 24
hours later new ideas emerge which were
stimulated by the brainstorm and another
thing that happens is that new group
norms are modeled if you have an
organization that doesn't have any kind
of normative practice like brainstorming
or innovation sessions or whatever you
want to call it then you really should
not expect that group to have creative
behaviors
the creative behaviors would be
anomalies they would be things that
people did in spite of the norms but if
you have regular creativity sessions
brainstorming sessions you're modeling a
norm that one of the things we do at
work is we have ideas once you've got
that as a group norm behavior and you're
tracking ideas that happen post session
I think you'll find that brainstorming
works on a bunch of different levels and
it's not simply the number of ideas we
counted at the end of the session but
there are two other little technical
things that I want to point out is they
always annoy me when people say they do
brainstorming and they don't do these
two things they don't prepare or warm-up
and they have really bad selection
criteria I was once doing a three-day
innovation session which was essentially
three days of brainstorming for a major
American consumer goods manufacturer
won't mention who they were we generated
you know hundreds and hundreds of ideas
that we're really kind of groundbreaking
ideas for this product category it's a
pretty stagnant low involvement product
category we also selected that I just
that we thought would be the most
game-changing for the organization but
at the end of the session they basically
selected ideas that would have been you
know that we could have you know
predicted they would have done they were
they selected a series of sort of line
extensions as their outcomes introduced
those products got sort of line
extension results and then you know kind
of claimed that the brainstorming
session didn't work so you have to be
careful about how you pick what you do
and just really simply you got to warm
up because you just came from a budget
meeting it just came from a meeting
where you're doing an or charity it just
came from something else where you're in
completely in your left brain during
your analytic and rational thinking mode
we want to get you to a synthesis mode
everybody doesn't have to you know sit
in a full Lotus but we do want you to be
thinking a different way so we have to
transition your thinking from analysis
to synthesis from left-brained or
right-brained
we typically do this with a bunch of
warm-up exercises you can play
Pictionary which is a nice visual game
probably everybody knows that game we
guess with someone's drawing you can
play other games we have bunch of a
bunch of exercises we've lifted from
improvisational theater which get people
moving and thinking and reacting in the
moment but if you don't do this
transition don't expect a person whose
mind is on their email in their budget
to suddenly create beautiful music with
you and your brainstorm it's not going
to happen you have to warm up an idea
selection is critical if you take all
these crazy wonderful ideas from your
brainstorm and you run them through the
filter of what's feasible you will get
incremental and feasible results you'll
get things you probably could have
gotten without going to the brainstorm
so there really wasn't particularly
useful but we suggest instead is that
you select for potential not feasibility
we believe that Allergan your
organization is good and it can take any
good to take a high-potential idea and
make it feasible but if you select for
potential you're going to get a
completely different set of ideas and
the way we do it is voting now
brainstorming is a group behavior on
everybody to participate and you want
them to be influencing and leapfrogging
off of each other's ideas we do voting a
completely different way we're now in
the evaluative mode this is the last
phase of the brainstorming session don't
forget this and this comes from our
bootcamp at the d.school you vote
silently we give everybody a bunch of a
bunch of different colored stickers and
we say go vote for your two ideas that
you think are most likely to succeed two
ideas that would be most likely to
delight and you know without regard for
any constraints on that and two ideas
that would be the most breakthrough if
we could ignore us you know the whatever
the fatal flaws we don't have enough
money to do this we don't have enough
time to do this this requires you know
reversing the laws of gravity whatever
that is you let people vote in they vote
silently without influence each other
and then you take those ideas and then
the next step after the brainstorm is to
process those into an action item list
how could we you know realize this
potential when you do that you get a
very different
a sort from the brainstorm and you'll
find that the results are much more
valuable to your organization much more
actionable okay I want you know just
wrap it up and said brainstorming can
transform the way your teams behave then
as data shows that novices with poor
setup and follow-through you know
probably brainstorm poorly I would argue
that even with novices you have to
practice and practicing brainstorming
will still set the expectation that one
of the things we do when we come to work
is we ask you to be creative they ask
you to act like a creative person just
fake it even if you don't feel creative
act like one and then I want to leave
you information a good brainstorming is
like great jazz you need to be expert
enough to create in the moment but to
improve your output you want to warm up
and then select ideas for potential not
feasibility the last thing I want to
talk to you about is space people often
come to the master class we're going to
do in June or one of the boot camps that
we run and they afterwards they say oh
can give me one thing one thing that
could take back to my organization that
would you know will work because I
really want to change my teams I want to
make them more innovative and I tell
them change your space so space creates
behavior this is a well-known in a
social psychological system if you look
at this space which is a classic
classroom and hundreds of these Stanford
the seats are all facing a stage the
stage is elevated from the seats the
seats are bolted to the floor so they
can't move they all face one direction
there's a little you know podium on the
stage obviously a professor is going to
get up there and lecture and when you
walk into a space like this you know
what you're expected to do you're
expected to sit down take notes perhaps
ask a few questions but the difference
between you and the professor is clear
and the organization of the room leaves
you almost no flexibility so it's really
clear what kind of behavior you will do
in
space here's another space I took
actually took this picture yesterday
this is up in one of the D school
classrooms for the class called
entrepreneurial design for extreme
affordability great class we send people
to Africa and we're working on
interesting hard problems in poverty and
and water and other things in the third
world when you walk into this room well
the first thing you notice it's kind of
chaotic the second thing you notice is
there's posted some visual stuff all
over the place and the walls and the
floor and the ceiling there is no stage
there's no clear hierarchy not clear
where the front of the room of the back
of the room is if you'll notice if you
look carefully at the picture you'll
notice that all of the tables are on
wheels all of the whiteboards the the
rolling white vertical whiteboards are
also on wheels you can't really see it
but some of the other you know furniture
and stuff in the back there's carts and
things they're all on wheels so if I
were to take a picture of this space and
another next tomorrow or the next day
they wouldn't look anything like this
so what sort of behavior do you expect
in a space like this well you really
don't know we've never probably been in
something like this before it's
certainly not as a graduate student and
so that allows us to do a couple things
it sort of changes the set of you don't
not sure how you're supposed to act then
as you come into the space and the
professors and teaching assistants greet
you they teach you new norms of behavior
which include lots of brainstorming lots
of group interaction you'll also notice
that you actually because I took a
picture of this space when it was full
of people you'd probably be hard-pressed
to tell the word the professors and the
way of the students there's no there's
no visible signs that create status
markers for you right so in that same
New Yorker article the author does
mention another study which demonstrates
physics as well what does work and what
works is proximity and raw in space a
Harvard study of thirty six thousand
over thirty six thousand scientific
papers that were ranked important
you know innovative papers in their
fields and they didn't the the
researcher did an interesting thing he
just looked at where the invent where
the first second third author were with
literally where were they sitting when
they wrote the paper were they three
meters apart 10 meters apart 100 meters
apart a kilometer apart different parts
of the world apart and the in in what
was the environment they were writing
the paper in and the two most
significant pieces of data data that was
the highly significant was that
inventors are innovators who were near
each other within three meters wrote
more innovative papers than inventors
that were separated and that people who
were in what he characterized as raw
unfinished or easily modified
environments did more significant and
more innovative work and there's a
famous building 20 at MIT it's mentioned
in the studies and there's some other
stuff that has been written about it so
it was a building that was just thrown
up right after world war ii as a sort of
temporary place to put some extra
researchers where they didn't have room
and then MIT sort of forgot about it it
was sort of an unfinished building but
it lasted for 30 years and almost all of
the groundbreaking research that came
out of MIT in computers computer
interface chips technology and other
things came out of building 20 and when
they talked to people about it was
because people love the building they
literally if you if you didn't have room
for a piece of instrumentation you just
cut a hole in the wall and stuck it
through the wall so people felt like
they sort of own the space and the
number of different groups that got put
in there because they were just folks
that were left over from didn't have
room in the nice buildings and who got
to talk to each other and
cross-pollinate turned out to be one of
the most significant factors for
innovation so drawing on that that
information that study
that's how we designed the d.school and
if you want to you know so we promote
colocation we promote multidisciplinary
collisions and we make a space that is
really sort of herbal by the students if
you want to do the same thing the
simplest thing you find a conference
room and it doesn't matter the uglier
the better take the loan with no windows
because nobody wants to be in there
anyway and create what we call a war
room all rooms have a couple of
consistent features they have persistent
information the the stuff you've been
brainstorming the stuff you've been
thinking about the stuff from the last
status meeting the budgets they're up on
the walls they're visual they're visible
and they don't come down you want to
remove status close status creates
hierarchy and inside hierarchies we know
we have to wait for the person above us
to have an opinion before we do so that
defeats creativity so you want to get
rid of all status clues and make the
space a space that when people walk in
doesn't matter if you're senior vice
president or the mail boy you know
you're the same these school classrooms
have no visible hierarchy and this
defeats that stage on stage that guy in
the front of the room is two lecturing
and you're taking notes we do it on
purpose to remove the difference between
us and the students and it's very very
powerful and creating innovation they
always make the room what we call self
authoring but that's why everything in
our room is on wheels I will sometimes
walk into a D school classroom expecting
to give a you know twenty minute kickoff
lecture and the students will say we
don't want a lecture right now we're
working in our teams and they will have
already formed team rooms in the room by
moving whiteboards around and and moving
some tables around and they'll be
working so but everything on we also
make sure that everything can be hacked
hackable space but nothing is precious
that people can change that this will by
the way drive your facilities people
crazy just tell them this room is
off-limits don't go in there it's kind
of like my teenage son's bedroom I don't
go in there I don't want to see what's
going on in there it's a mess all the
time but when you can hack the space
self author-it the information is
persistent and it's a space that lowers
the
you know evens out the hierarchy you
will find that you've created a room
that demands a different kind of
behavior so if you want references are
more of this - of the people who are
responsible for the d.school space which
is published a book called make make
space how to set up the stage for
creative collaboration it's a great book
just came out and you can get the Scott
darling Scott wit top are the authors
and these slides be available you can
pull that down if you're interested in
learning more about how to create a war
room or create other other spaces in
your organization that will increase
innovation and create you know create
team formation and normative behaviors
that are different and the New Yorker
article which is actually online as a
podcast you can listen to it you can
read it from the January 30th New York
edition it is online and available I
think for free but takeaways again
changing your teams and transforming
them into innovative teams it's just
about changing behaviors you can change
the people the same people are not going
to change their personality that's
that's fixed but you can change what
they expect to do when they come to work
the two most powerful methods we know of
doing this is move to the Jazz
brainstorming model and create a space
that demands these new behaviors the
most important thing you can do as a
manager is model that behavior be the
creative person so that they know they
have permission to act just like you
this is a little scary because you may
not have permission to act that way from
your manager but that's where you show
leadership and you model the behavior
you have to act differently and oh by
the way you have to reward differently
one of the things you have to reward for
is you know attempts one of the things
you have to reward for is failure that
may be an interesting thing in your
organization but if you can model the
behavior you want and you act
differently and reward differently your
teams will follow your lead and remember
to be patient it takes about eight weeks
to establish a new habit thank you for
your time I'm going to turn it back to
Stacey who's going to tell you a little
bit more about the things that oh excuse
me
yeah anyway I'm going to turn it back to
the SCPD folks and they're going to tell
you about
the master classes coming up and a
couple of other things thank you bill
I'm Joyce rice the director of marketing
for the Stanford center for professional
development I really appreciate your
talk as a member of multiple teams I
look forward to modeling some of these
design thinking concepts when I get
together with my teams again and I just
maybe we need to call those jam sessions
talking about jam sessions we again
would like very much to encourage you to
consider the innovation masters series
program that would be held here at
Stanford coming up in June it is a very
highly interactive enterprise you will
have an opportunity to meet a number of
people from other organizations and let
me take it kind of the next step here
that we've had several meetings now over
a couple of years of this program and we
are delighted for instance that last
year more than 70% of the participants
actually came from international
locations so it's a marvelous
opportunity to meet people and to
exchange ideas with folks who also come
from all sectors private public
nonprofit and government entities during
this program over the three days have an
opportunity to explore and experiment
with many of the brainstorming and
Design Thinking ideas that bill was just
talking about and and actually begin to
work on problems do things in a lot of
different ways carry through the whole
design thinking process and one of the
things that many participants appreciate
is that they do form relationships here
and networking opportunities that extend
beyond the meeting here at Stanford one
of the things that program participants
really appreciate is that these faculty
members from the design group at
Stanford are highly engaged in the
program and you will have a chance to
hear from them not only during a portion
that they may be leading but they are
participate throughout the program and
are exchanging ideas with each others as
well as as with the participants so if
you've had a chance to think a little
bit about some of the ideas that were
expressed and the notion of the
innovation masters series we'd
appreciate hearing from you here in a
poll about the level of your interest in
the Design Thinking course and the
innovation masters series okay I think
we'll close the poll
and will conclude at this point with
first of all - thank you very much for
joining us today we hope that you will
have an opportunity to come back we will
be hosting additional webinars on this
particular topic as well as other
webinars that are hosted by the Stanford
center for professional development and
at this point we would be happy to
entertain some questions that you might
have we have a few minutes and Bill
Burnett will we'll address those okay I
got a couple of questions that I could
probably address on one question is what
is ethnography you know in in cultural
anthropology or ethnographic studies
it's the it's a series of techniques and
tools Ruby's interviewing we use
observation on-site observation we use a
couple of other sort of reportorial
techniques to investigate a need so if
we were working on designing a news
service let's say for a bank or a
financial institution rather than try to
get a bunch of smart people in a room
and think of think of things we might do
we start by shadowing people using
financial services at a bank talking to
what we call extreme users people who
never go online don't trust an online
you know service system people who use
it exclusively to manage all of their
financial information so we would in you
know we both interview and observe
people having interactions with the
services and having things that are
negative or difficult interactions and
ethnography is just sort of the blanket
term for the techniques of doing what we
call need finding trying to get at the
tacit where the unspoken needs in any
kind of problem whether it be a design
problem or a policy problem our services
problem a couple of people have asked if
I could repeat the reference to the New
Yorker
a New Yorker article so this is in The
New Yorker in the January 3rd edition if
you just go yeah general I should be
generating January 30th three zero
edition if you go online and either
search brainstorming doesn't work New
Yorker article or some variation of that
I think you'll find the podcast and
again the podcast is free you can listen
to the author be interviewed by The New
Yorker staff on what this article says
about research both the research sites
some references to the research on why
it doesn't work with novices and also
why co-located spaces that are raw I'm
seeing to create the best most fertile
grounds for innovation yeah so another
question is can I recommend any other
reference material on design thinking or
for how you define good problems yeah
there's a couple of there's a couple of
authors that I would point you to Tim
Brown who's the current CEO and
president of IDEO IDE oh the innovation
consultancy wrote a book on design and
as I'm thinking that I think would be a
good starting point so that's Tim Braun
from ideal another if you like a more
business focused approach Roger Martin
who is the Dean of the Rotman School of
Management at Toronto University so you
know who's widely quoted as saying it
shouldn't be a MBA a Masters of Business
Business Administration because we don't
teach people to administer things it
should be an MVC a master of business
creation because that's what I want my
students to know how to do and he wrote
a book called the design of business and
he talks about design thinking but uses
sort of a different model of different
terminology I think that's a pretty
interesting book to read if you're
looking for something and then
one of our professors dev Zev Pattanayak
P hat P 80 and aik wrote a book on
empathy and need finding he runs a in
addition to being a professor here he
runs a consulting firm called jump
associates and a desk book our need
finding is probably the best source for
looking at how you use need finding
ethnography and the techniques of sort
of anthropology to discover the latent
needs and frame those in a way that you
can use for a design or an innovation
activity so the three authors again are
Tim Brown the CEO of IDEO Dave pet
Knight the first named ee-vie last name
PA TN aik who has written them probably
the best book on empathy and Roger
Martin who's the Dean of the business
school at Toronto who had a book called
the design of business those would be
three resources I'd look at first and of
course they have some bibliographies in
there of other books that are you know
fundamental to them if you're looking
for some you know for the first book or
the foundational book on brainstorming
brainstorming was allegedly invented
although I know if that's really true
maybe just invented and branded by a
game guy named Alex Osborn back in the
50s he was at a major New York City
advertising firm and he was the guy who
first formalized the use of
brainstorming to create creative ads so
Alex Osborn has written a number of
books on the subject would be probably
the guy to go to as the source for
brainstorming information and then if
you want to understand why how to make
yourself more creative and how to become
a better brainstorm you want to look at
a book by James Adams we often use this
as a text for the master series James
Adams is a professor emeritus here now
and his book was called conceptual
blockbusting a guide to better ideas
so Jim Adams talks about both how
creativity works and what blocks it you
know so four categories of blocks and
makes the claim that if you're aware of
how you get block and how you can get
over these stumbling blocks to
creativity you will be a more a much
more creative contributor both in
brainstorming sessions and individually
let's see I've got one other question
here in order to turn novices into
experts with brainstorming other things
how do you get people to stop being
judgmental without sounding judgmental
and in turn poisoning the mood of the
meeting you know I think we talked about
the rules of brainstorming and in some
ways that's an oxymoron how can a you
know how can the event which is supposed
to be creative and free and you know
exploring in the moment have rules well
in the same way that we all agree is
jazz musicians to play basically the
same song even though we're going to
play it differently this time than we've
played it before and when it comes my
turn to solo I may decide to insert a
different song inside my solo just as a
reference to something else but we still
agree that there are is going to be a
structure a beginning and an end and a
way in which we decide to pass the lead
back and forth right and pass the solo
back and forth I think that's the reason
we have rules in brainstorming it
depersonalized is the don't critique
rule are when you're when you're the
facilitator of a brainstorm and you're
trying to get people to not be critics
to not be judgmental and particularly
with early brainstorming sessions and
people who are not familiar with it I
mean they believe that their expertise
is being called for in the meeting and
so if they hear of an idea that won't
work they feel it's their obligation to
tell you that that idea won't work
you're very you know so if they know if
the rules are posted we put typically
put the rules all around the room so you
can just sort of point to it and say
don't criticize that can be personalized
you know the message but also
I think it's it's important you know to
sort orient people to the the purpose of
this process it's not actually asking
for their expert opinion in fact it's
asking for their you know for sort of a
nonlinear Association of things that are
not about their expertise but simply
about their being in the moment with
with the rest of the group so you can do
it with I typically do it with humour
physically with early brainstorm errs
and people who like to criticize we used
to have a little bell you like one of
those little you know bells that you hit
and tell somebody if somebody's at the
front desk you hit the little Bell hit
the little Bell because that you heard a
critique and then it just keep moving I
try not to dwell on the the person who's
being judgmental too much but just
ping-pong to the next person and let the
ideas continue to flow people who tend
to stop the brainstorm with their
judgment will be quickly overrun if
there's a lot of energy in the room and
then they'll want to participate in that
energy rather than continue to be the
critic and if you have somebody who is
persistently critical or doesn't really
understand the method why the method of
non judgment is important just remove
them their bad brain simmer you can be a
brilliant classical musician you can be
the best you know you can be yo-yo ma
the best cello player on the planet and
be a terrible improviser you may need
the structure you know a Bach's cello
concerto number one in order to express
yourself but you must buy every note
exactly the way it's written your
expression is comes from the variation
the slight variation and intonation that
you bring to the piece but you may be a
terrible improviser right that doesn't
mean your bed cello player just means
you're not in my brainstorming session
so you know certain personalities will
have more difficulty with this than
others but everybody can learn to behave
this way if they're properly motivated I
think that's about as much time as we've
got I'm going to turn it back to Stacey
to close
thank you everyone
the webinar will be available within a
week for download on demand download if
you are interested in downloading the
slides please click on the icon at the
top of the toolbar it is located in the
icon with three papers stacked on top of
each other thank you very much for your
time have a wonderful day thank you